[LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
Good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to this last
session of the day.
Thank you for coming here and
taking up this time between you
and going to have some
fun over at AT&T Park.
What we're going to do today
is talk about Spotify's journey
from on premise data centers
to Google Cloud Platform.
I'm Peter-Mark Verwoerd.
I'm a solutions
architect here at Google.
Speaking with me today are
Max, who's a colleague of mine
from Google, and Ramon and
Josh, who are both from Spotify.
And I will let each
of those gentlemen
introduce themselves when
they come up to speak.
The four of us were all
part of a core team composed
of Googlers and Spotifiers that
made this migration a success.
And so we're going to cover what
that was and how we did that.
And to do that, I'll introduce
the next speaker, Max.
[APPLAUSE]
MAX CHARAS: That's nice.
[INAUDIBLE]
So this presentation
is around how
we executed a multi-datacenter
migration to GCP.
We worked with over 100
teams in two countries.
And we migrated over 1,200
services and 20,000 data
processing jobs.
This is a very active
collaboration between Google
and Spotify still.
So the presentation is
split into four parts.
We'll start with
an introduction,
where we cover the
Spotify organization
and kind of how it works.
But we'll also walk
into the higher level
goals of the migration itself.
After that, we have
two main chapters,
and they cover the migration.
One is for the user
facing services
and the other is
for data processing.
And after that, we have lessons
learned during the migration.
So a note to you all, though,
this migration-- the strategy
is very tailored to
Spotify, both technically
and organizationally.
So if you would want to do
something like this yourself,
it might look very different.
So let's kick off the
intro and here is Ramon.
[APPLAUSE]
RAMON VAN ALTEREN: Hi.
My name is Ramon van Alteren.
I'm the Program Manager
for the entire cloud
migration at Spotify.
Now before we start diving
into this migration, what
I would like to do is take you
through the two main reasons
why we wanted to move to cloud.
And the first
reason is something
that applies at a
global company level.
If you think about
the amount of effort
it takes to maintain compute
storage, and network capacity
for a global company
that serves more than 170
million users, that's a
sizable amount of work.
Just think about
the amount of work
it just takes to replace the
servers that you depreciate
over every three years.
That's a lot of work to do.
And if I'm really honest, what
we really want to do at Spotify
is be the best music
service in the world.
And none of that work working
on data centers actually
contributes directly to that.
We'd much rather spend all that
focus, attention, and energy
into becoming the best
music service in the world
and build features for our
customers and our users
and our creators that make
it the best music service.
So we saw a good
opportunity to take
some of that work
towards Google,
and allow our own
engineers to focus
on Spotify-specific actions.
That's one thing.
But the second thing is--
and that helps with
choosing a cloud,
is that if you start
analyzing this,
one of the things that
is really important to us
is fast product development.
And if you start looking at
the ecosystem of services that
are slowly being
built on top of cloud
parameters, like instances,
networking, and storage
capacity, that's an
ecosystem of services
that allows you to
move much faster
and deliver a much better
product faster to users.
Think about things like
BigQuery, or PubSub,
or Dataflow, those
things are building
blocks that allow us to
innovate a lot faster.
So let's take a look
at where we started.
As Peter-Mark
already mentioned, we
had everything in
on-premise data centers.
We're known for running a large
microservice architecture.
At the time we started
this entire process,
we had about 1,200
different microservice
that served our users.
By now, it's several
hundreds more.
And we had a pretty
mature engineering culture
around that, with lots of
automation around deployments,
spinning up instances,
spinning down instances.
This was something people
could fairly easily do.
We ran our service out
of four data center
sites in the world--
one on the West Coast, one on
the East Coast of US, and two
in Europe.
Each of those sites is
essentially a standalone copy.
Most of our backend
in those data centers
is essentially control
plane of the surface.
So the content
delivery, the music
that gets delivered to your
phone and to your desktop
or to your speaker comes out
of CDN networks and owned CDN.
So it's not coming out
of our data centers.
That's coming from
a separate place.
And we're big on data.
We're a data-informed company.
We have about 20,000
data processing
jobs, 2,000 unique workflows,
and about 100 petabyte of data
when we started.
And all of that had
to move to cloud.
And lastly, we had
about 100 teams.
Important to know is probably
that those 100 teams each owned
operational responsibility for
the services they developed.
So that means they're
on call for those.
But also own sort of the
entire business problem
that they're trying to solve.
Here's the three main goals
we had with this migration.
First, link to the first reason.
We wanted to minimize disruption
to our product development.
But you can't stop
feature development
for the duration of
a cloud migration,
because that's completely
unacceptable both to our users
and our stakeholders.
The second thing we felt was
really important was speed.
Hybrid states-- where
you're in both states--
are both expensive, but
the rules are risky.
You force engineering
teams to keep
two cognitive models, one for
on premise and one for cloud.
And everything you
deploy, you need
to go through the process
of does this work on cloud,
does this work on premise--
for incident mode,
similar problems.
The last goal we
had was clean up.
This is a forcing function
for your long tail,
that you don't end up with
small things that are still
running in the data center,
and make sure that you finish.
What might come as a
big surprise to you
is that most of
this cloud strategy
actually came from the
infrastructure groups.
The people maintaining
those data centers,
building the network,
building the instances,
ingesting all the
hardware-- those
were deeply involved in building
out this cloud strategy.
And we spend a lot of time
prepping and involving them
in that.
Part of that
involvement was talking
about what does your job look
like once we moved to cloud.
But it's to some
degree a scary thing
to move from a completely
owned stack to a cloud,
and what are you going to be
doing as an infrastructure
engineer?
And we spent a lot
of time talking
about how that would evolve.
And the net result of that
was that the entire group
of engineers, which are
some of the most deeply
respected engineers inside
Spotify, have a lot of contact
with feature teams and often
own the larger scale core
services that we have, ended up
being advocates for our cloud
storage.
So we did a big
kick off with them.
We built a whole
set of prototypes.
And during those prototypes,
we found two key blockers.
One broker was the lack
of VPC when we started,
which is now there and
available for everyone.
And the other problem
was related to VPN.
And we'll talk about-- in the
different migration tracks,
we'll talk about these
two different blockers.
The last thing we did
was build a minimal use
case and a good one.
If you want to move a
multimillion dollar company,
you can't show a
small prototype.
You have to show you
actually can viably run
your business on top of cloud.
So we built a minimal
working prototype
that played music and
was capable of processing
the data coming out
to pay out royalties.
I think I would like
to spend a little bit
of a word on dependencies.
I think for every
migration, but especially
for cloud migrations,
dependencies are important.
But if you look
at a microservice
typically servicing a
single customer request,
takes about 10 to 15 services.
And the same is true
for our data processing.
A single data
processing workflow
will often involve multiple
intermediate datasets
and transformation
steps across these.
Stop the world and everybody
migrate is not an option.
We talked about that.
So that means that
you need to find
a strategy that allows your
teams to move independently
without having to migrate
all their dependencies in one
go as well.
And we felt it an
important problem
to solve first in
this migration.
And with that, I would
like to invite Peter-Mark
up here to talk about
some of these strategies.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: So
when we talk about migration
to the cloud in the abstract,
it breaks down generally
into about two
different strategies.
The first strategy
is lift and shift.
That's when you try to keep
your architecture as simple as
possible to whatever you have.
You minimize your changes
to virtual machines,
application layer, databases,
network, and so on.
The upside of this is that
you can focus on speed
and keep complexity down
while you're migrating.
The downside is that
you can potentially
increase your costs, because
your workloads can't really
use the elastic design patterns
or higher level services
available on Google Cloud.
The other strategy is
some form of a rewrite.
That's where you're taking
some part of your application,
or potentially all of it,
and completely rewriting it,
using more Cloud-native
products and architectures.
Complexity of this is basically
directly proportional to how
complex is your
code base, how well
does the development
team know it,
and how much change
are you trying
to make to that application.
So as Max said before,
this presentation
is divided into two parts.
And the first part will
cover the migration
of the user facing services,
what we're calling the services
migration.
And the second
chapter will cover
the migration of data processing
workloads, so data migration.
Services migration used a lift
and shift strategy throughout.
And the data
migration use a hybrid
rewrite and lift
and shift approach,
depending on the kind of
workload that they had.
And so right now,
we're going to dive
into the services
migration with Ramon.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RAMON VAN ALTEREN:
Hey, I'm back.
[LAUGHS] So we talked
about two blockers.
So let's dive into
them a little bit.
The first one was VPC.
There was no VPC
when we started this.
It's a new feature.
We build it collaboratively with
Google, based on our feedback.
But what we
essentially found was
that if you had
microservices in a project,
the only way for them to talk
to a microservice in Project B
was for the request to go
essentially out to the internet
and then come back in.
And that didn't really
work that well for us.
We're a pretty latency
sensitive service.
That was not acceptable.
We briefly try putting our
entire 120 team engineering
organization in one project, but
that really didn't work either.
So we quit that pretty quickly.
What we ended up-- or
what Google ended up
stepping up to the
plate and developing
was VPC, which
allows you to build
similar to an
internal network that
connects multiple
of these projects
and that can cross-talk
easily enough.
So we ended up with
a decision where
we said, OK, every
service is going
to live in a single project.
So not every team
has a single project,
but every service
has a single project.
And this gives team good
control over their own destiny.
They get to do the
things that they
need to do for their
service in that project,
and if they shoot
themselves in the foot,
they shoot themselves in the
foot, not the entire company.
And that's important
to us as well.
I think the second blocker
that we found in this was VPN.
When we started, and
this is 2015-2016,
right, we tried connecting our
data centers to Google Cloud
to solve the dependency problem.
So you can move
one service, and it
could connect to its
dependencies in data center.
That takes, with
1,200 microservice,
quite a lot of VPN bandwidth
and quality on that.
And to be honest, I think
the VPN service at that time
was more or less
scaled on, let's
connect an office with
25 developers in it.
And then we showed up with
four data centers and multiple
10,000s of service.
That didn't really
work that well.
Again, this was a
collaboration with Google
where the quality was
improved fairly rapidly.
And we managed to get
this working solidly.
So we build several
multiple gigabytes
of network pipes between
our different data
centers towards
Google Cloud to allow
for that dependency
problem to disappear.
Now after that, we
spent some time building
just enough infrastructure
to make it actually
slightly easier to spin
up capacity in cloud
and it wasn't on premise--
slightly faster, slightly
easier, same tool set.
Another key realization
in the service migration
is that we could decouple
service migration
from moving our user traffic.
170 million plus
users generate a lot
of traffic towards our service.
If you have to do that full bang
in one migration, that's hard.
You can do the work of
migrating a service to cloud,
and do the development
work you need
for that without necessarily
moving all that traffic.
So we deliberately
separated these two
with different
roadmaps, where we
focused on getting
all these applications
ready to run in Google Cloud,
all these backend services.
And then we had a
separate road map
that allowed us to gradually
connect more and more users
to GCP and that
allows us to control
both reliability, the user
experience, and our migration
speed.
And it allowed us to control
how much traffic was flowing
over these VPN links, as well.
The next thing we did was
build a small migration team.
It was a hybrid team staffed
out of both Spotify engineers
and Googlers.
And the first thing
we did as preparation
for running that
migration team was we
built a visualization of
the entire migration state
and I'll show that
to you in a second.
The second thing we did was we
built a completely standardized
migration sprint program.
How do you migrate a
backend service to cloud?
Well, here's a template
program on how to do that.
We built some teaching material
for common migration cases,
like how do you migrate
your data store?
How do you make
migrate a Cassandra?
How do you migrate
a Java application?
And we created a set of teaching
material about Google Cloud.
What is changing?
What is important
for you to know?
Here's how that
visualization looked.
So every bubble is a system.
The size of the bubble is
proportional to the amount
of machines that the system
uses, the sort of capacity
that the system has.
If it's red, it's
in a data center.
If it's green, it's been
migrated to Google Cloud.
And this had a number of
interesting side effects.
I think one, it saved me as a
program manager a lot of time
doing status updates about
the state of our migration,
because people could
just go and look.
That was nice.
But the side effects were
interesting, I think.
What ended up happening was
that several people that
would work in a team--
and if you look at
the visualization,
those blue-ish circles represent
teams and departments--
so someone heading up one of
these departments or in a team,
would go and hunt for
these red bubbles.
And go, look, why is
that not migrated?
And that was pretty
useful to us.
The other thing that
it did was that it
created a real sense
of accomplishment
in teams that were migrating.
From the start to the
finish of this migration,
they could directly
see what impact they
were having with their work.
And we updated this
multiple times a day.
So literally, once they
migrated the system,
they could see the
bubble go green.
And that helped a
lot with motivation.
This is how it
looked by the time
we stopped doing the migration
with backend services in May
2017.
So we stopped the
sprint program.
Someone is wondering about the
big red bubble in the middle.
That's our Hadoop cluster.
We did not migrate that one.
So starting a sprint,
we did two things.
One, and this is a really
important one, was focus.
What we essentially
did was we negotiated
with these different
product departments
where there was room in
their product roadmap
to spend one or
two weeks migrating
so they would not get in
trouble with their deadlines.
The con side of that
was that we asked
them to stop all other work--
so no feature work, no other
things, no minimal things,
no small things on
the side, nothing.
All the engineers would focus,
for the duration of the sprint,
only on cloud migration.
The second thing we did
was an intake meeting where
we covered a number of things.
One was what's the amount
of systems that you own?
Which ones do you
want to migrate?
What are the ones that
you don't want to migrate?
Why?
And that was a pretty
interesting start to do,
because in many
cases, people said,
well, we're planning to
deprecate this anyway
in three months.
So we can actually speed
it up and do it now.
So in many cases, it
actually reduced scope
instead of increased it.
The other thing we looked at
was large data storage systems.
But if you own multiple
terabytes of data,
it actually takes
time to transfer that.
And it's a bit silly to sit
with a whole group of engineers
to wait until it's
transferred to the other side.
So often, if there were
very large systems,
we would start that
transfer earlier
so we could hit the ground
running while starting sprint.
The last thing we did was an
operational risk assessment.
There is a difference between
moving a Tier 3 service that
does a minimal feature
that degrades gracefully
for our users and a Tier 1
service that if you fuck it up,
the entire service goes down.
And then that
makes a difference,
so it's important
to know about that.
Excuse the language.
[LAUGHTER]
So with that, I would like
to ask the two people that
joined me in the migration team
to come and talk about this.
We split the work in
this in three big blocks.
And about half of the work
was actual migration work.
And the interesting
thing was that some
of the feedback we
got out of engineers
was that it was boring.
It actually worked
fairly simple.
You just redeploy the
application on cloud
and it just works.
That was really nice to hear.
So it took far less time
than we thought it would,
in many cases.
What we did was we asked
people to focus on one region
they're taking
production traffic.
But also spin minimal capacity
up in the other regions
that we were using.
And then that one region
was taking enough traffic
to see any performance
or reliability issues.
A key thing was, where
you get these people want
to fiddle with the systems and
make them better at that time.
So we were pretty
strict about no,
we're not cleaning
up tech [INAUDIBLE]..
We're migrating at this time.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: So once
the majority of the systems
had been migrated, usually
by the end of the first week,
we would deliberately, in
a controlled, recorded way,
actually induce failures in
their newly migrated systems
to see how comfortable
and where the teams were
in managing incidents.
I mean, basically, we just
started breaking things,
slowly, until they
started noticing.
And then we watched
and saw and recorded
how they would recover.
So while it was absolutely
fun to break things
and watch teams
scramble, there were
a couple of interesting
things that came from that.
The first thing-- there were
a couple of obvious ones.
So the first one was make
sure that the monitoring
systems were properly extended
to the new cloud deployment.
Make sure that
that's all working.
If we started breaking something
in and the team didn't notice,
that was obviously a
big red flag that's
something they need to monitor.
But I think what was really
interesting was when something
broke, team noticed,
recovered, and we're
debriefing and talking
about how we did what we did
or what the failure mode was.
And teams starting to look into
different ways of monitoring,
and said, well, you
know, we noticed it.
But if we were monitoring
on this metric instead
of that one, not
only would we have
noticed, but we'd have
gotten to the root cause
much more quickly.
And so that kind of
iterative process
over deliberately breaking
things really kind of
helped a lot of teams.
And then finally,
we had this playbook
that they get start going
to and start building
on for failure
modes in the cloud
that they may not have
had to deal with before
or encounter before.
And so that was really a great
experience to kind of watch
that discovery process and
kind of build on that as we
went throughout the migration.
MAX CHARAS: Great.
So we also had four
educational packages.
And you can see these
at the bottom here.
I think it's important
to state, like, we
did this for more or less
every team that we encountered.
So they had to go through
these lectures and workshops
where we discussed
different topics.
The first was GCP support.
And that was really about
how to interact with support.
And it was about interacting
with support, both
during incidents as well as
for more long term development
support.
And it was really important,
the small things here,
like seeing that people actually
created support accounts
and opened the case
to see how it worked.
So when in the future they
would have an incident,
everybody in the team would
feel comfortable interacting
with support.
The second one was
networking and what
we covered here was really
the different semantics
of networking between
GCP and on prem.
Because the teams were
used to operating on prem
in very specific data centers.
The third was a
product overview,
where we went
through, most notably,
the different database
options within GCP.
And the goal here was to
allow the different teams
to feel comfortable moving
to more managed solutions
in the future.
Now we didn't do this
during the migration itself.
This was something
for future purposes.
And last, but not least,
we also covered costs,
so that everybody in the
team would feel comfortable
monitoring and understanding
the different semantics of costs
on GCP.
RAMON VAN ALTEREN: So as I
showed in the visualization,
by May, we had done
the migration sprint
with nearly every
team in the company.
And at that point, even during
those migrations sprints,
we slowly started increasing
traffic towards Google Cloud.
Well, we can control
where users connect.
So more and more users
started connecting to GCP.
And during the
migration, started
gradually increasing that.
It allows us to measure and
control the user experience.
This was a key thing
for us to make sure
that it continued to be good.
We have a reputation for
carrying around all the world's
music in your pocket, and if
you press play, it starts.
So this user quality
was important for us.
And we wanted to make
sure that that did not
degrade for moving to cloud.
And this allowed us to measure
that really effectively.
The other thing we did was
manage reliability risks
with this.
And the last thing is
we were able to control
the amount of users we put on
cloud, based on the migration
speed that we had.
The more services we had
in GCP, the more users
we managed to direct there.
And then, by the time we had
all applications or all services
on GCP, we did a
number of things
while increasing more and
more traffic towards 100%.
The reliability program we
ran with individual teams
helps teams reason about their
reliability for their system.
There is also an aspect
of the entire service.
So one of the things we did is
we ran company-wide reliability
exercises, where we closed
an entire data center, where
we closed an entire
cloud region,
and made sure that we
could still provide service
to our users.
Just before Christmas in
December of last year, 2017,
we hit 100% users.
But at that point, the first
data center was already closed.
We closed our San Jose data
center here on the West Coast
in October 2017.
And that's a pretty
strong signal
for people with long
tail applications
that are still running
in data centers--
that they need to get a move on.
There's a roadmap for the rest.
We have already closed
our secondary data center
in the US.
And there's two
data centers left
in Europe, which were already
scaled down significantly.
But they'll close by
the end of this year.
This concludes our overview
of the services migration.
I would now like to hand over
to Josh, my colleague to talk
about the data migration.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSH BAER: Thanks, everybody.
So my name is Josh Baer.
I lead the data migration.
And that's what I'm going
to talk about right now.
So just to recap a
little bit about where
we were before we moved
our stuff over to GCP--
we called ourselves the largest
Hadoop cluster in Europe.
And we were able
to call ourselves
that because nobody ever
corrected us, so it worked.
We were certainly one of the
largest clusters, for sure.
So we had about 20,000 jobs that
ran every day from around 2000
workloads.
And as Ramon mentioned
at the beginning,
this was from as many as 100
different teams distributed
throughout Europe and the US.
So this is a view of what
our dependency graph looks
like, all those jobs
interacting with each other.
And this is actually
a vast simplification
of our dependency tree.
Because if we
showed the full one,
it would be way too wide and
way too deep to actually project
it, and you wouldn't
actually see a lot of it.
So the crazy thing
about this graphic
is each little smudge that
you might see there is a job.
And each job has an input
and each job has an output.
And those inputs are
the dependencies.
And those dependencies could be
from a totally different team
than the team that you work on.
And it could be in
a different location
than the location you work on.
So it's fairly complex to try
to move these, all those jobs,
over to GCP without causing
downstream failures.
And that was really
the challenge.
And overcoming this challenge
through our strategy
is what I'm going to
talk about right now.
So you can now
understand the complexity
of what we had to move.
And one thing we
could have done is
to tell everybody to stop
everything they're doing,
shut down the Hadoop cluster,
copy all the data over to GCP,
copy the state, and start
things back up again.
Now unfortunately,
we couldn't do this.
Because as you've
seen in this graphics,
even with 160 gigabit
per second network
link that we had to
Google initially,
it would take us
around two months
to copy all the data that
we had on the cluster.
And because we're a business
that relies on our data
to pay our labels, and
we rely on our labels
to provide content, and
we rely on our content
to provide a service
for our users,
we wouldn't be
much of a business
if we were down for two months.
And since every node
in the dependency tree
earlier could represent
individual team
we had a rough job
of moving things
without disrupting other users.
So what could we do?
So our strategy was
to copy lots of data,
essentially to duplicate data,
both on premise and on GCP.
So as you moved your pipeline,
as you moved your job over
to GCP, what you would do is you
would copy your dependencies,
all the data.
You would set up
a copy job to copy
you dependencies over
to GCP, and then you
could port your job over.
Then if you had
downstream consumers,
you might have to copy
the output of your job
back to our
on-premise cluster, so
that the downstream
consumers weren't broken.
And since the bulk of our
data migration lasted around 6
to 12 months, we were
running a lot of these jobs
to fill gaps in our
dependency trees.
As you can see in the
graphics here, at peak,
we had around 80,000
jobs that copied data
from on premise to the
cloud and around 30,000
that copied data back to on
premise, so a lot of copies,
a lot of duplicate data,
and a lot of complexity.
And I mention that these
copy jobs were not exactly
easy things to get right.
So especially early on,
we had the 160 gigabit
per second network bandwidth.
And we found problems
that when jobs were broken
and they had to catch up, they
would saturate that network
bandwidth.
And then we had our
high priority jobs
that were getting blocked
by maybe jobs that
aren't such high priority.
So we had to figure out
how to get that working.
That was one challenge that
we disrupted over time.
And we learned it's massively
important in this transition,
when you're in the hybrid state,
to over provision your network
bandwidth.
Another problem
that we ran into,
or another lesson
that we learned,
was to avoid using the VPN
whenever possible in these copy
jobs.
And fortunately, GCS has
application layer security,
so you really don't need
to use the VPN to copy data
back and forth.
So while we still
couldn't tell everybody
to stop everything they're
doing and move everything
to the cluster,
what we could do is
say, stop everything
new that you're
doing on our on-premise
cluster and start writing
all the new things on GCP.
And the benefit
of that is there's
some natural attrition as people
are rewriting or replacing
their jobs.
They'll just kill off their
old ones on the on-premise.
But what about the jobs
that already existed
and weren't being replaced?
So they had two paths to choose
from, as was mentioned earlier,
and that's what I'm
going to highlight.
The first path was called
the forklifting path.
So pure lift and shift
wouldn't work for us.
And there's a few
reasons for that.
The first one is
that we really wanted
to move away from this process
where we had one single Hadoop
cluster that managed
all our data jobs
and one team that managed
that Hadoop cluster that
bore all the operational
responsibility if it
was up or down.
We also had to adapt
to the assumptions
that we made from
on-premise cluster
to what the reality was in GCP.
So for example, our
orchestration framework really
depended on atomic moves.
And in GCS, they don't
have that same atomicity,
so we had to build some
tooling to bridge that gap.
So at the start of migration,
we actually spend a lot of time
to build infrastructure
and tooling to make
it easier for our teams to use.
And I want to highlight
a few of those tools
that we built in our process.
And I should mention that
all of these are open source,
so you can check
them out, and maybe
they will be useful to you.
The first tool that I
want to mention is Styx.
So early in our previous
on-premise world,
we had the concept of
these long-lived edge
nodes that launched jobs.
We wanted to move to a
world where you could just
containerize your
job in Docker and use
Kubernetes to schedule it.
But we had to build
a scheduler for that,
and that's what Styx is.
So in addition to being more
fault tolerant, this process,
it allows us to be very
flexible across the cloud
and very flexible with
how we use our resources.
And we don't have these really
hand-tuned edge nodes anymore.
The second tool that
I want to highlight
is something called Spydra.
And in a few words, Spydra is
Hadoop cluster as a service.
Now you might be
thinking, there's
already Hadoop cluster as
a service that GCP offers.
Its Dataproc, right?
That's true.
But what we wanted to do is
go one level of abstraction
higher so that our
users really didn't
have to worry about
learning a new tool,
learning how Dataproc offers.
They just write
their job, and we'd
take care of the spinning up
and the tearing down of clusters
by ourselves.
And we'd take care
of the net tooling,
centralizing the logging,
so that if their job fails,
they can still figure
out what's wrong with it.
So this was great and
troubleshooting was still easy.
And there was no need for that
centralized infrastructure team
and no need for that centralized
big main Hadoop cluster.
So the forklifting path
was primarily the path
that teams had to take if they
had a lot of other priorities
and they couldn't take
the time to rewrite.
But I'm going to talk about
the rewriting path now.
And that was really advantageous
for some other teams.
So in this path, you would
either rewrite your job
using BigQuery or
a tool called Scio,
which I'll talk about
in a second, which
is essentially Dataflow.
So the benefits of this is this
was massively exciting for all
our engineers, right?
One of the real advantages
for moving to GCP
is our engineers
could go and play
with the latest and
greatest tech, the stuff
that we had read about
in papers, that we always
had wanted to try out.
So this was exciting for them.
And the benefit for
the teams is this path
is actually fully managed, too.
So they don't even have to worry
about spinning up and tearing
down these Hadoop clusters.
We just can outsource
that to the Google teams
to provide the managed
infrastructure for us.
And this was also useful
for teams that didn't really
feel comfortable just porting
over their jobs using the lift
and shift, using the
forklifting path.
And they might not
feel comfortable
because maybe they inherited
these data jobs somewhere
in the past and they never
actually had looked at them,
so they wanted to dig
into them a little bit.
And while they were
digging into them,
they might as well rewrite them.
So like the forklifting
path, we ended up
creating some tooling to
support our users in this.
And the main tool that
I'd like to support,
that's also open source--
you should go check it out
in GitHub--
is a tool called Scio.
So Scio is essentially
a library that's
wrapped on top of
Beam or Dataflow,
which simplified
some of the less
familiar functions of Dataflow
for our data engineers.
And it was a bit closer
to scalding, something
that we used pretty extensively
in our Hadoop world.
And the great
additional benefit--
it's got real tight
integration with BigQuery.
So if you just want a
few specific columns
that you want to
process over, you
can use BigQuery to
get those columns,
and then use Scio
to process them.
So it's been really
successful, and I'd highly
recommend you check it out.
So but this path, too, wasn't
without its challenges.
The biggest thing is it required
a much larger time investment
from teams, right?
They're not just
porting their jobs over,
they're actually rewriting it.
And as engineers,
what usually happened
is when you start to
rewrite it, you say, hm.
That thing I did-- what was
I thinking two years ago when
I wrote that?
I would want to
re-architect it, too.
So when teams usually
told me that they
would rewrite their jobs
in around two weeks,
it usually lasted a month.
And when teams told
me, it was a month.
It was usually three months.
So that leads into this quote
here, Hofstadter's Law--
that it always took longer, even
taking into account that law.
So towards the middle
and end of our migration,
we actually had to tell people
to avoid the rewrite path
altogether.
Migrate their stuff using
the forklifting path, then
if they really did want to
rewrite it, or re-architect it,
it was all already on GCP.
So we could still hit
our migration targets.
So that's our strategy.
I want to quickly highlight
the tactics that we
used to move teams over to.
So at this point, we've provided
the tooling for the teams
to forklift their jobs over.
And we've provided
libraries that they
could use to rewrite their
jobs on GCP natively.
But for other teams,
the reality was still
that ramping up to speed
with these new tools
was a challenge.
There were new things, and they
didn't really have capacity
to learn new things, or maybe
they had specific edge cases
that the tools didn't cover.
So to solve that, we decided
to create a temporary team.
Temporary teams can be
composed of both infrastructure
engineers and the feature
teams, the people that
understood the business logic.
So the benefit of having
our infrastructure engineers
is that they're the people
that created the tools.
So they understand
really well how
to adapt jobs to get
them to run on GCP.
And the benefit of having
the feature teams work on it
is they understood
the business logic.
And they were
especially important
because they would own
the jobs when it's on GCP.
And they would
have to understand
how their logic worked.
So this task force
lasted around one
to two weeks of highly focused
sprints with one main goal.
And that was to take all your
jobs, port them over to GCP,
and oh, yeah, don't break
your downstream consumers.
Use those copy jobs.
So now that was the
tactics and strategy.
I'm going to quickly highlight
what our data stack looks
like now on top of GCP.
So the first tool that I'd
like to highlight is BigQuery.
And maybe some of you saw--
Nicole was in the
audience over there
to do a talk yesterday on how
we use BigQuery at Spotify.
When we started
seeing BigQuery used,
it really to underscores
a powerful explosion
in lowering the friction for
asking and answering questions
and how adoption
really increased.
As you see now, we have around
25% of Spotify's employees use
BigQuery.
And before the
migration, I think
we had around 50 monthly
active users for Hive
that were asking and answering
jobs using that [INAUDIBLE]..
Another tool that I would
like to highlight is Pub/Sub.
So Pub/Sub feeds both our
batch and our real time data
processing jobs.
And the great
thing about Pub/Sub
is it's significantly
lowered our operational costs
from before the migration.
Then I'd like to highlight
both Dataflow and Dataproc.
So we're heavily,
heavy users of both.
Dataflow, in particular,
I think a few months ago I
talked to the PM.
And we were the
largest Dataflow user.
I think we're still at least
one of the largest now.
We run around for
5,000 jobs per day.
And almost all of
these jobs are using
Scio, which our engineers
absolutely love to use.
So you might be thinking, what
happened to Europe's largest
Hadoop cluster, right?
What did we do with that?
So at the end of Q1 this
year, we held a big gathering
in our Stockholm office, in
the cafeteria on the top floor.
And we had one of the
first engineers that
ran a Hadoop job at Spotify
press a big red button shutting
down the power in our London
data center that was our Hadoop
cluster.
And the crowd sat
there and watched
a live feed of our data center.
And the first thing
they noticed is all
this whirring and buzzing
of fans in the data center
immediately went silent.
And it was crazy.
And then one by one, you'd
see all these blinking lights
stop to blink, and
shut down, and go dark.
And that really signaled
the end of our life
as on-premise Hadoop user and
signaled the start of our life
as fully native on GCP.
And to complete that
day's celebration,
we had an "Office Space"-style
dismantling of one of our name
nodes that was used early on.
And as you could see there,
really just let the steam out
and signaled that transition.
So that concludes the migration.
We want to highlight-- and
bring everybody on stage--
and highlight a few of
the most important lessons
that we learned
throughout the process.
[APPLAUSE]
MAX CHARAS: Great.
So the first lesson is prepare.
And I think it's
important to state
here that we prepared
for probably two years
before actually
doing the migration.
And each migration
took roughly a year.
So we spent a lot
of time preparing.
Now what we really did was we
tried, as you can see here,
a minimal use case that showed
the benefits of moving to GCP.
But when we say minimal
here, its important to
say that it wasn't
a small thing.
It had to have been an important
feature for the entire business
to show the true
value of moving over.
For each of these
minimal use cases,
we refined the model
for moving over.
So over time, it became
better and better.
One thing that's also
important to note
is that your early adopters,
if you decide to do this,
are super important.
Because they will be
your developer advocates
later on in the organization
as your migration progresses.
Great.
That was the first
lesson, prepare.
RAMON VAN ALTEREN: I'll
take the second lesson.
The second lesson is focus.
It is truly amazing what you
can do with a team of engineers
if you focus on a single thing.
We literally had sprints that
lasted a week where we moved
more than 50 to 70 services.
It is amazing.
Do that.
It helps a lot.
It will also help your
business stakeholders.
They'll be a lot happier that
there's a short period of time
that there's no product
development instead
of an extended period of time.
And if you try doing
migrating while doing
all the other priorities that
you have within the business,
your migration speed
will slow to a crawl.
And that will make this a
far more difficult process
than it has to be.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
The third lesson
is creating a migration team.
Both of the two different
paths, the services and data
migration, used a
migration team to help
enable the teams actually
doing the migrating
and accelerate that process.
And the way we looked at
it was to go into teams
and act as guardrails for them.
The teams that maintain the
services, know the code better,
know the services
better than we do.
But we came in
and said, you know
what, we're here to
make sure that you
know what you need to know.
We can pass on past
experience, past learnings,
and make this as
efficient as possible.
We're here to be
resources that you need,
whether you need to
talk about new libraries
that you're doing
for data migration,
or maybe talk to
somebody at Google
because you're curious about
how something else works.
And what was great
about that is that we
got to carry the experience
from each migration
from team to team to
team, so you're not
doing, say, five teams
migrating in isolation.
Team one and team four run
across the same roadblock
and spend the same amount of
time solving the same problem.
Well, what we could do
is take that experience
and carry it forward.
Carry it throughout.
And so each sequential
migration actually
improves on the
previous, in terms
of what we could carry through.
And so that was
very, very helpful
on both sides of
those migrations
to be able to move
those teams forward.
JOSH BAER: And the last lesson
that we wanted to highlight
was to get out of hybrid
as fast as you can.
So in the data migration,
as we mentioned,
all these copy jobs back
and forth to clusters
was both expensive, in
terms of network bandwidth,
but also complex
in terms of people
had to figure out where the
jobs were actually running
and where the dependencies were.
It was also a problem
in the services,
as Ramon highlighted early on.
So when you were in
an incident mode,
you had to figure out
where is the problem?
Is it in the on-premise tooling?
Is it in the GCP tooling?
Or maybe is it in
the glue in between?
Yeah.
And this also, as
Ramon mentioned,
adds cognitive overhead
for your teams.
And when you want to
focus on the world
just purely on the cloud,
that's not something
you want to think of.
So if you move to the
cloud as fast as possible,
you could just focus
on being cloud native.
So that concludes
the presentation.
We'll now take
questions, I think,
using the mics on the side.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]
[LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]